What if humans had gills and could
breathe underwater just like fish?
How cool would it be to swim alongside
dolphins and sea turtles for as long as
you want? What? Breathing under water,
meaning we could finally
explore all of earth's waters.
Would we give up this terrestrial life
and move to the bottom of the sea?
Maybe we'd see how polluted our
oceans are and cleaned them up.
This is what if, and here's what would
happen if we could breathe underwater.
Humans for sure aren't
qualified for aquatic living.
How long can you hold your breath?
Well,
if you're not a professional free diver
and you don't belong to the Badjao
people who can stay under
water for up to 13 minutes,
then you can probably only hold
your breath around two minutes.
But with no practice, it's likely you'd
want to give up after just 30 seconds.
If only we could take a
deep breath underwater.
Our lives would never be the same or
would they turns out just having the
ability to pull oxygen out of the water
wouldn't be enough to turn you into a
fulltime aquatic resident. Why? Well,
if you move to the deep ocean,
you'd suffer from hypothermia.
That's when your body temperature
falls below 35 degrees.
Your heart and your nervous
system malfunction and your
organs are on their way
to complete failure. You couldn't survive
in cold water longer than 90 minutes,
but what if he didn't go that deep? Could
you settle down near the surface? Well,
when we set, our bodies aren't quite
suitable for living underwater.
We didn't mean just breathing.
Not only do we not have enough body hair
or fat to warm us up and cold water and
prevent hypothermia, but we
also lack flippers. Of course,
he can buy a pair of these,
but let's be honest,
our limbs aren't too efficient
when it comes to swimming. Also,
our eyes aren't adapted to see underwater,
but if you weren't near the coral reefs,
there wouldn't be much to see anyway.
Expect 24 hours of darkness,
partly money.
You need to learn sign language as
you wouldn't be able to say a thing.
There would be nothing to
make your vocal cords work,
not after your lungs filled up with
water and forget about text messaging.
In fact, forget about any electronics
that aren't water resistant.
If you've ever dropped your phone in a
pool, you know that it just won't work.
And just imagine having your
dinner served under water.
Ever tried eating pasta
at the bottom of the sea.
Gil's wouldn't let us move under water,
but they help us in many other ways.
Underwater construction
would be much safer.
Falling off a skyscraper in
the ocean wouldn't kill you.
We might switch to a new public
transportation system, underwater subway.
The rushing waters would
take you to your destination.
Just don't forget your neoprene jumpsuit
to keep you warm on these underwater
commutes. We'd see how polluted
our oceans are. Sooner or later,
we'd start cleaning up all the plastic
we've been throwing in the oceans and all
the chemicals we've dumped in there.
We'd start growing a lot
of salt tolerant crops.
Keenwah beats CKL to feed ourselves and
other plants like widgeon grass to feed
fish and shrimp.
So Gill's would in fact change our lives.
Maybe one day with the
magic of bioengineering,
we'll be able to take that
deep breath deep underwater.